bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de parlement hebdo en compagnie cette
semaine de delphine girard bonjour
delphine the road nous voici partis pour
un tour en 45 minutes de l'actualité
politique et parlementaire de la semaine
marquée bien sûr par les manifestations
en egypte qui tourne à l'affrontement
entre pro et anti moubarak le président
égyptien annonce son départ pour
septembre sans calmer la rue les états
unis et l'europe réclame un processus de
transition une médias et puis les
nouveaux embarras de michèle alliot
marie la ministre des affaires
étrangères à qui l'on reproche d'avoir
utilisé l'avion privé d'un proche du
clan ben ali lors de ses vacances de
noël en tunisie
la ministre se dit meurtri par ses
attaques enfin un zoom sur un débat
écolo qui tourne à la polémique
politique le gaz schisteux peut être une
mine énergétique du futur mais très
polluante pour les nappes phréatiques
le débat a fait son entrée cette semaine
dans l'hémicycle est avec nous pour
commenter l'actualité de cette semaine
yves cochet bonjour député de paris
alors vous faites partie des quatre
députés verts de l'assemblée nationale
et puis vous êtes bien sûr l'un des deux
candidats déclarés pour les primaires du
parti écologiste pour 2012 sauf si
nicolas hulot se présente
vous nous direz justement s'il en a
vraiment et puis vous pourrez d'autant
plus nous en parle et que vous êtes un
habitué des primaires à vous étiez déjà
été le candidat malheureux des primaires
en 2007 face à dominique voynet vous en
souvenez évidemment et puis vous nous
direz aussi dans cette émission pourquoi
vous avez interpellé aussi
vigoureusement dans l'hémicycle michèle
alliot marie à propos de ses vacances en
tunisie aux lilas allez on passe à tout
de suite en revue l'actualité de la
semaine avec vous yves cochet et on en
sait désormais un peu plus sur le
calendrier des primaires chez europe
ecologie les verts
c'est à huis clos que le conseil fédéral
d'europe écologie les verts s'est réuni
dimanche pour statuer sur la désignation
du candidat à la présidentielle le
vainqueur sera déclaré le 24 juin ou le
9 juillet en cas de second tour deux
candidats à la primaire sont déjà a
déclaré eva joly et vous yves cochet
quant à l'homme providentiel de ces
primaires nicolas hulot il réfléchit à
se présenter et devrait faire connaître
sa décision d'ici avril jérémy hartmann
il n'était pas là mais tous ne parler
que de lui
l'ombre de nicolas hulot planait samedi
sur le conseil fédéral d'europe écologie
les verts
l'animateur télé doit annoncer d'ici
avril s'il se lance dans la
présidentielle
en attendant on s'impatiente un peu chez
les écolos à commencer par sa principale
concurrente déclaré
nicolas hulot tous les jours
je pense à à nous ce que nous devons
faire
gray encore tena gauchy au programme à
construire eva joly met la pression sur
nicolas hulot pour qu'ils participent
aux primaires du parti
l'ancienne juge d'instruction se dit
déterminée à aller jusqu'au bout mais
difficile d'organiser une élection
interne sans la candidature officielle
d'un des favoris
je veux pas comparer une candidate
déterminer officiellement candidate est
un bon candidat
on ne peut pas nous attendre la décision
de quelqu'un même c'est aussi du lustre
que nicolas ici on le surnomme déjà le
dsk des écolos et c'est donc sans lui
qu'on était fixé les dates des primaires
elles auront lieu fin juin les partisans
de nicolas hulot aurait préféré
septembre alors à la tribune daniel cohn
bendit tente de satisfaire tout le monde
les deux candidats déclarés et les
autres si demain eh bien il faudra d'une
manière sereine essayer de trouver la
solution pour avoir la meilleure
candidature alors ira ira pas
chez europe écologie tout le monde est
suspendu à la décision de nicolas hulot
la clôture des candidatures est fixée au
15 mai est ce que c'est vous êtes
candidat mais vous avez dit que vous
étiez prêts à vous retirer à retirer
votre candidature si nicolas hulot se
présente est ce que ça brûle pas un peu
votre image
non je suis candidat puisque pour le
moment rien à deux avec madame joly et
il ya une sorte de calendrier officiel
le méthode encore qu'on puisse y revenir
parce que ça a été adopté dans des
conditions livre douteuses et puis je
connais évidemment nicolas hulot on a
déjà parlé ensemble et depuis six mois
jeudi que si jamais il était candidat on
le saura dans à peu près de moi eh bien
je me retirer parce que je pense que
c'est lui le meilleur tout simplement
selon différents critères enfin le
meilleur pour avoir le meilleur score
tout simplement que quand même le
meilleur critère au moment où on fait
les élections présidentielles aient
envie d'y aller
alors oui il a envie le problème c'est
qui il est actuellement à la tête de
quelques pme on peut dire qu'à sa
fondation la fondation nicolas hulot
trentaine de personnes légalement ses
émissions sur tf1 ushuaïa bon donc il
doit évidemment voir de quelle manière
ces gens-là survivront
allah près hugo au moins de ce point de
vue là bon il y avait également sa
famille qui est un peu réticent ça s'est
levé il ya également une préparation un
peu politique psychologique
il s'était déjà préparé vous souvenez en
2006 2007 il avait dix ans que j'y vais
j'y vais pas ça va durer assez longtemps
non pas un peu plombé d'ailleurs déjà
les primaires à l'époque c'est ce qu'a
laissé entendre cécile duflot il est
certain que c'est pas tellement les
primaires parce qu'on avait déjà une
candidate y remet mais c'est peut-être
la campagne de madame voynet qui avait
été un peu difficule 2 justement parce
qu'on attendait hulot puis qui n'est pas
allé alors bien sûr elle avait signé
comme les eaux que le pacte écologique
qui était déjà un bon projet politique
pour l'écologie pour la france là je
pense qu'il va pas le refaire
d'ailleurs il a dit c'est dans deux mois
dijon début avril qui le fera et donc un
an avant l'élection sera si oui il y va
ou sinon il va pas si les bâtards bas il
y aura des candidatures comme madame
joly comme moi peut-être d'autres et
s'il y va moins je me retirais et je
pense qu'à ce moment-là peut-être que
eva joly qui dit évidemment vouloir
aller jusqu'au bout ou moi aussi mais
peut-être sera tirs at elle simplement
parce qu'il y aura une sorte de vague du
low et sera clair pour tout le monde que
c'est le candidat on pourrait dire
naturel ou sécuriser jusqu'à 10 collège
royal est président c'est pas comme
porter une émission télé oui j'ai vu ça
je crois que c'était et hier enfin bon
je le dis en f1 au moment de la visite
en seine-saint-denis
il est vrai est la raison que une prime
très vite ancien la politique c'est pas
la même chose que l'émission de télé
mais je dirais que nicolas hulot c'est
pas la même chose que patrick sébastien
et que lui il aura avec lui tous les
militants l'écologie politique d'europe
écologie les verts
il aura aussi une préparation qui l'a
déjà fait je le dis en 2007 il avait
écrit un livre qui était déjà très
politique
il connaît bien les politiques ce qui
existe on dit quelquefois oui mais il
est quand même un petit peu à droite
parce qu'il est copain elle non il n'est
pas il moi il m'a dit si ç'avait été par
lionel jospin qui avait été élu en 2002
baïla il se sera adressée à lionel
jospin
simplement ça a été de nouveau chirac
puis ensuite sarkozy il s'adresse aux
enfants qu'aux ong en tant
qu'association au pouvoir en place un
peu comme monsieur bernard thibault de
la cgt paris discute avec le mini du
travail lequel qu'ils soient bons par
contre si jamais et comme je le souhaite
dans deux mois il bascule et qu'ils
vraiment il change sa vie
et il vient avec nous dans le camp
politique je pense qu'il sera prêt il a
déjà assez souvent des séminaires le
travail pas simplement sur l'écologie
que physique parce que ça il connaît ça
mais sur sur les relations
internationales sur la dette de l'état
sur le budget de la france sur le
chômage sur les retraites en temps et
donc il élargit considérablement
moi je le souhaiterais la preuve c'est
que je me retirais bon il faut voir si
je vais à joli bain ses mandats corps ne
sera pas forcément d'accord mais comme
tout le monde n'est pas forcément
d'accord avec le fait que l a vraiment
percé dans les sondages et même dans
l'opinion publique
quand même logist de la dernière pluie
ça n'est pas très gentil et non plus 10
ha oui c'est ce qui était écrit non il
lui dit je le confirme c'est que eva
joly elle le dit elle même est assez
nouvelle en politique est assez nouvelle
en écologie ça fait quoi à moins de 2
ans et donc on veut pas dire qu aux yeux
de nos concitoyens parce que c'est les
citoyens qui votent finalement pas les
militants à rêvasser l'écologiste
historique on a toujours connu
non ça elle pourra pas le faire même si
elle a des grandes capacités pour
apprendre et pour parler de tas de
choses allaient lundi toujours jacques
chirac se porte bien c'est lui même qui
l'affirment à des journalistes qui
l'interrogent dans la rue après des
rumeurs de maladie d'alzheimer en ce
lundi on apprend aussi que la date de
son procès sur les emplois présumés
fictifs de la ville de paris est
toujours maintenue au 7 mars
kamala d'oreilles aux caméras qui
l'attendaient devant son domicile
jacques chirac n'a qu'une chose à dire
il va bien
l'ancien chef de l'état réagit aux
rumeurs qui le disent atteint de la
maladie d'alzheimer
une théorie que son épouse avait démenti
un peu plus tôt dans la journée les
médecins lui ont dit qu'il n'a pas la
maladie d'alzheimer je les crois il a
toujours dit qu'il voulait être traité
comme un justiciable comme un autre et
il a dit qu'il irait à son procès et il
le fera
le procès des emplois fictifs un procès
historique prévue début mars
mais pas question d'évoquer des
problèmes de santé illustration avec un
soutien socialiste
le corrézien françois hollande qui parle
d'un homme toujours aussi cohérent et
bien à son âge il a connu c'est des gens
nuit de santé est alors laissons le dire
ce qu'il a à dire montrer ce qu'il a
montré et ne faisons pas là l'espèce
d'utilisation d'une faiblesse possible
l'ancien chef d'état est poursuivi pour
détournement de fonds publics abus de
confiance et prise illégale d'intérêt il
risque 10 ans de prison et 150 mille
euros d'amendé alors yves cochet on sait
que la mairie de paris a trouvé un
accord avec jacques chirac un accord
financier
l'association anticor demande
l'annulation de cet accord va bien voir
ce que ce que ce que dira le tribunal
les verts au conseil de paris était
farouchement opposés à cet accord ils le
sont toujours
oui nous pensons que ça ressemble
beaucoup à un accord entre amir du temps
à chanter la justice il ya eu évidemment
un préjudice financier avec ces emplois
fictifs
eh bien on va s'arranger
plus loin on est d'autant plus que
c'était leur père c'est l'ump où il
parti c'est quand même le président
chirac lui même
enfin tout ça ressemble à quelque chose
qui consiste à ne pas dire la vérité sur
ce qui s'est passé vraiment alors qu'il
ya des gens qui ont déjà été condamné
pour cela et donc on a pas de partie
civile s'est s'inquiété lieu c'est
ennuyeux enfin parce que c'est
absolument scandaleux si c'est avéré
comme d'ailleurs ça l'a été pour
d'autres personnes vous voulez vous que
monsieur juppé ok maintenant au
gouvernement a quand même été condamné
du temps où ils étaient tous à la mairie
de paris
bon moi je ne peux pas ne pas imaginer
que monsieur chirac n'ait pas été au
courant de tout ça bon on verra
j'espère que le procès aura lieu qu'il
viendra eu la leur de dire oui je ne me
déroberai pas la justice qui répondra
qui n'aura pas le père de mémoire et
commencera enfin la vérité dont je
soupçonne qu'elle est celle qu'on sait
déjà
justement s'il s'affiche en bonne santé
il prend également le risque d'être
entendu dans d'autres affaires c'est
quand même courageux pour la part de son
entourage de le présenter comme ça en
bonne santé
ben c'est pas courageux si c'est réel
puisque ce sont des médecins d'après
madame chirac elle elle même qui ont
jugé qu' il est certes un peu fatigué
parce qu'il n'est pas de tout jeune âge
mais qui là encore tous les moyens de
réponse le ch se déplacer etc
il est normal que d'abord ce procès lui
l'élu mars puis ensuite d'autres
affaires ils soient jugés
nous nous sommes en plus qu'autre toutes
les juridictions d'exception on pourrait
parler de la ferveur puisque les
possibles qu un jour aussi il dit devant
la cour de justice de la république est
un tribunal d'exception l'on veut le
droit commun pour tout le monde
notamment les gens qui ne sont plus en
fonction comme le président ou l'ex
président chirac
donc dans ce cas là si elle doit
répondre devant la justice
et s'il est finalement coupable de
quelque chose eh bien il doit payer
enfin pour plus que le président schir
aviv on a bien profité de la république
depuis toujours il n'a jamais vraiment
travailler à l'extérieur des
institutions
il doit aussi être auditionnée
éventuellement pas dans la sphère
karachi en tout cas les familles qui le
demandent également dans l'angolagate
vous pensez qu'il faut comme ça sortir
toutes les affaires sur un président
vieillissant ou comme certains ou vous
comprenez qu'on puisse dire bon
peut-être peut-être on peut
le laisser un peu qu'en pensez vous non
non je ne le pense pas je vous le dis je
crois que en effet comme on vous le
voyez vous le dites vous même il ya
beaucoup d'affaires 10 ans qui concerne
l'ex président chirac qu' à chaque fois
c'est quand même une question de
responsabilité politique aussi bien
entend tenir le pari en tant qu à
l'époque président du rpr ou bien en
effet dix ans premier ministre puis
président de la république il faut
vraiment que dans toute cette affaire
une par une et spécifiquement bien
entendu regardez quelle fut sa
responsabilité et si elle est engagée au
sens qu'il est reconnu coupable
eh bien il doit avoir une peine comme
n'importe quel justiciable très bien on
passait la journée du mardi l'egypte en
pleine confusion
plus d'un million de personnes réunies
au caire place tahrir et dans plusieurs
villes d'égypte mardi du jamais vu pour
réclamer le départ d'hosni moubarak dans
la soirée celui ci annonce qu'il ne sera
pas candidat à la prochaine
présidentielle
alors que les états unis appelle à une
transition rapide
mathilde de terriers aujourd'hui le
président égyptien a peut-être perdu un
de ses derniers alliés barack obama ce
n'est le rôle d'aucun autre pays de
choisir les dirigeants égyptiens seuls
les égyptiens peuvent le faire et ce qui
est clair et c'est ce que j'ai dit ce
soir au président moubarak c'est qu'une
transition ordonnée doit être entière
elle doit se dérouler pacifiquement
et elle doit commencer maintenant un
coup de fil de la maison blanche qui
pressent le pas de moubarak vers la
sortie
passer deux heures seulement après le
discours du dictateur à la télévision je
vous le dis en toute sincérité
en dehors des circonstances actuelles je
n'avais aucune intention me présentais
pour de nouvelles élections
le président ne renouvellera pas son
mandat mais entend toutefois gouverner
jusqu'en septembre chez les manifestants
c'est la stupéfaction une ultime
provocation à la fin d'une journée test
sans précédent avec le pari pourtant
gagné
il une marche de plus d'un million de
personnes au caire et à alexandrie le
plus important pour nous c'est qu'il
doit partir aujourd'hui pas demain pas
la semaine prochaine ce pas pour les
prochaines élections
vendredi prochain on se dirigera vers
son palais d'héliopolis et on sortira un
ultimatum lancé avant ce discours par
mohamed el baradei prix nobel de la paix
aujourd'hui leader principal de la
contestation
du côté des diplomaties aussi le temps
presse après avoir longtemps était en
retrait plus que modéré nicolas sarkozy
sort de son silence et souhaite que la
transition s'engage sans tarder et
acculé seul contre son peuple est contre
la majorité de la communauté
internationale
le sort d'hosni moubarak semble
désormais scellé reste à savoir combien
de temps ils veulent supporter alors
aujourd'hui est-ce que hosni moubarak
peut encore rester jusqu'à la prochaine
élection présidentielle
haye a déclaré jeudi à la télévision
américaine qu'il ne pouvait pas le
laisser le pouvoir en place ne pouvait
pas laisser le pays dans le chaos alors
moi je n'ai pas d'information
supplémentaire à celle que tout le monde
peut avoir en france mais j'entends ce
que disent ils ont les diplomaties et
même les chefs d'état ou de gouvernement
différents pays et je trouve remarquable
que dans le cas de la tunisie comme dans
le cas de l'egypte le président obama
ait réagi rapidement et en très peu de
mots à une quarantaine de meaux a suffi
pour dire quelle est la posture des
états unis en gros c'était d'essayer
d'avoir une transition non at il dit en
anglais c'est à dire maintenant et donc
ça ne peut pas être mois de septembre
comme était la date dix ans des
prochaines présidentielles
c'est une transition fin avec ou sans
hosni moubarak puisqu'ils parlent déjà
de transition oui mais une transition ça
peut être surtout sans hosni moubarak a
je crois que le programme a bien jugé
peut-être quelques autres aussi en
europe que le le peuple de manière un
peu symbolique réclament le départ de
moubarak
dans la mesure où ils représentent
l'ensemble de ces dictatures il faut
bien le dire depuis une trentaine
d'années donc c'est la même chose que
ben ali en tunisie
il ya évidemment des changements réels
qui doivent avoir lieu le gouvernement
les questions à la fois le canal de suez
de pétrole d'émeutes de la faim
il ya aussi le prix disons des oeufs du
lait de la viande de la farine de
l'huile qui augmente c'est aussi ça la
révolte du peuple égyptien ya pas
uniquement la question institutionnelle
il ya tout qui se mélangent
mais je crois ça doit se faire en effet
maintenant c'est à dire dans les jours
et semaines qui viennent
est ce que l'europe n'a pas un peu tardé
la france a raison une fois de plus on
connaît les la politique arabe de la
france depuis général de gaulle qui
était une bonne politique
il semble qu'on n'y soit resté au sens
que madame alliot marie et d'une manière
générale même monsieur kouchner
jadis n'ai pas vu qu'ils avaient des
évolutions très fortes notamment
d'aspiration populaire et qu'il fallait
au moins par l'intermédiaire de
l'ambassade discuter avec les opposants
et avec les comités disons lui peuvent
ils ça sent ils ont une espèce de le
posture diront différentiel vis-à-vis
des dictateurs je crois que c'est fini
et notre diplomatie et les chefs de la
diplomatie ont failli en ce sens elle
mardi toujours la réponse du
gouvernement au meurtre de laetitia en
loire-atlantique les ministres de
l'intérieur et de la justice pointe une
défaillance de la chaîne pénale et
annonce une série de mesures dont la
création d'un office de suivi des
délinquants sexuels et violents
le ministre de l'intérieur brice
hortefeux y revient dans l'hémicycle on
l'écouté nous avons décidé l'inscription
automatique et immédiate sur le fichier
des personnes recherchées d'un
délinquant qui ne satisferait pas ses
obligations
nous avons décidé comme vous l'avez
voter que ce sera bientôt promulguée
l'extension obligatoire du port du
bracelet électronique
nous avons aussi décidé la création d'un
office rassemblant les services de
l'intérieur de la justice de la santé
pour mieux repérer et mieux anticiper
les délinquants alors c'est vrai que
face à la barbarie
je vous le dis monsieur le député bonnec
nous sommes totalement déterminés et
face à ces actes monstrueux notre
société n'est pas impuissante
alors on connaît la suite jeudi nicolas
sarkozy parle de graves
dysfonctionnements et promet des
sanctions dans la foulée les magistrats
de nantes vote
une sorte de grève puisque c'est une
semaine sans
ambiance nicolas sarkozy at il été
injuste avec la justice il l'a été pour
les raisons politiciennes parce que je
crois que c'est une sorte de début de
campagne enfin et ça fait très longtemps
qu'il est en campagne nicolas sarkozy et
que il remet la sur d éventuels débat de
2012 est bien la question sécurité la
question de la justice la question de la
gendarmerie et de la police
la question de la délinquance qui sont
chanson le commerce en escient ils ont
leur a collé un peu les voix d'extrême
droite puisque c'est comme ça qu'il
avait essayé disant de les réduire en
il croit que ça va recommencer avec
marine le pen moi je crois que c'est
évidemment pas comme ça qu'il faut faire
il ya déjà d'ailleurs en cinq ans non en
six ans il ya eu déjà cinq lois qui ont
parlé de la délinquance et de la
récidive et de la récidive
ça n'est pas une loi supplémentaire
évidemment qui va satisfaire
alors là c'est plutôt la création d'un
office bien sûr qu'il faut que la
justice notamment la justice mais aussi
la police et la gendarmerie et plus de
moyens mais appliquons plutôt les lois
avec des moyens supplémentaires plutôt
que le dire on va encore faire une fuite
en avant
c'est sur cette question des moyens
michèle alliot marie a mis en place la
réserve judiciaire elle veut faire un
rappel à des magistrats et des greffiers
retraités c'est une bonne idée ou c'est
du colmatage
oui non c'est du colmatage je crois
qu'il faut qu'ils aient vraiment des
magistrats supplémentaires des
conditions également de détention qu'ils
soient moins indigne que celle qu'on
voit dans notre république sais pas si
vous avez visité des maisons d'arrêt où
les prisons mais enfin la moitié d'entre
elles sont vraiment très délabrées et
insalubres an passé c'est indigne quoi
et donc il faut un peu plus d'argent
pour le ministère de la justice
tout simplement pour caler les moyens à
la fin le fonctionnel pour rendre la
justice et également du côté
pénitentiaire d'avoir quelque chose de
décent pour les prisonniers
il ya un député ump richard maillé qui
propose que les maires soient mis dans
le circuit et un pouvoir de contrôle
si on les informerait sur la venue sur
leur commune d'un condamné pour faits
graves
c'est quoi ça c'est une double peine ou
c'est une
solution il ya déjà avec le bracelet
électronique quand tu peux lire la
géolocalisation et tout ce qui concerne
la sécurité la délinquance la justice
doit rester du pouvoir de l'état enfin
c'est vraiment le pouvoir régalien si
bien il y en a en france et par
conséquent ce sont les moyens de la
justice
alors il fallait peut-être pas fermé
autant de tribunaux fermés autant le
commissariat là on peut faire un débat
budgétaire comme il y en a eu d'ailleurs
au sénat et à l'assemblée
mais je pense pas que les mères qui sont
déjà officier de police judiciaire mais
pour les raisons
rapide il en de rapidité ne doit pas en
plus être les auxiliaires de justice je
ne crois pas alors mardi encore la
fondation abbé-pierre interpelle les
politiques dans son rapport annuel elle
pointe la grave pénurie de logements
plus de trois millions et demi de
personnes sont mal logées
le rapport débusque aussi les
difficultés de menace jusque là
épargnées comme des propriétaires
modestes
incapable de faire face aux charges
chloé buffard carton rouge contre le
mal-logement plus de 10 millions de
français sont touchés
parmi eux 3 millions 600 mille sont très
mal logées c'est-à-dire qu'ils vivent
dans une cabane ou à plusieurs dans une
chambre d'hôtel et 33000 sont sans abri
des chiffres qui ne cessent d'augmenter
car à cause de la crise économique
les classes moyennes sont aussi
concernés maintenant les classes
moyennes commencent à être touchés par
cette crise parce que le l'accession à
la propriété devient extrêmement
difficile pour eux à cause d'une
influence mais les prix et mais ils ont
aussi du mal à se loger dans le parc
locatif puisque il ya très peu de
logements privés et ils sont très chers
la fondation demande donc au
gouvernement plus de moyens elle estime
à 500 mille le nombre de logements
manquants par an la fondation demande
une dépense des pouvoirs publics de 2%
de pib en faveur du logement en 2010
on aura fait 1,96 record depuis 1986 25
ans tu que les aides publiques au
logement 25 ans et c'est un record battu
la fondation abbé pierre dénonce aussi
la politique du tous propriétaires voulu
par nicolas sarkozy en 2007
les aides fiscales seraient
insuffisantes pour aider les plus
modestes à acheter et certains
propriétaires basculerait même dans le
surendettement
en face au mal logement que propose le
candidat aux primaires que vous êtes
eh bien je vois que nicolas sarkozy et
son gouvernement propose tous
propriétaires ne le dit pas on dit
actuellement c'est plutôt touche
précaire et c'est donc la précarité la
précarité énergétique mais aussi
l'insalubrité et la difficulté de se
loger
attention quand même le tous
propriétaires européens l'accession à la
propriété conçoit lisant riches ou
pauvres n'est pas la politique principal
c'est qu'en france cette partie une
particularité française là on a envie
d'être opprimé il faut pouvoir l'être et
pour pouvoir rembourser on voit bien que
dans les commissions départementales de
surendettement
il ya beaucoup de gens qui n'ont pas pu
honorer et finalement leur crédit donc
faut faire très attention et l'autre pas
c'est évidemment le rêve des villes très
étalé avec le pavillon dit dans quelque
part et puis le petit jardin mais ça du
point de vue écologique alors c'est tout
à fait insoutenable notamment lorsqu'il
ya le transport en commun pour les
servir lisant le manière assez dense et
rapide
ce genre de lotissement donc le crois
qu'au contraire nous on est favorable à
des villes plus compact ça ne veut pas
dire en hauteur ça ne veut pas dire
qu'ils aient bel hymne enviée par
l'espace vert mais disons des petits
collectifs c'est mieux que ce soient les
pavillons individuels soit d'être l
entoure donc voilà au point de vue alors
il ya également il faut bien dire à des
excuses territoriale et ça je le dis
parce que moi je suis francilien entend
depuis une quinzaine d'années mais
auparavant j'étais breton c'est pas du
tout les mêmes prix ni la même axé sur
la propriété ni les mêmes loyers en
bretagne ou en ile de france et on veut
toujours à grandir l'île de france
il faut maîtriser vraiment la croissance
de l'île de france pour dire non il ya
d'autres emplois il ya d'autres manières
de vivre car je vois les départements
les agents qui font de la pub sans venez
chez nous on n'a pas tous les
embouteillages toute la police sur l'île
de france et on vit très bien et on
travaille très bien je crois qu'il faut
refaire de l'aménagement du territoire
qui a été un peu délaissé depuis dix ans
créer des pôles économiques attractif
c'est ça c'est ça
mais tout de l'emploi mais pas en ile de
france alors que l'île de france
bénéficie ce soit pour la recherche
l'économie l'industrie dires de beaucoup
plus de subventions que les autres
régions c'est dommage vous aviez
soutenir le squat de l'avenue matignon
du collectif jeudi noir pour la
réquisition des logements vacants avait
complètement rayé loi de réquisition à
paris bon les chiffres sont difficiles
mais enfin c'est uniquement pour paris
peut estimer à 30 mille le nombre
d'appartements ou de logement qui sans
vacances qui veut dire à peu près cent
mille personnes en moyenne qui
pourraient être logées s'il y avait
cette loi de réquisition qui existent et
qui était appliqué tout à fait favorable
à ça alors passer au mercredi et aux
nouveaux ennuis de michèle alliot marie
elle avait déjà créé la polémique en
proposant l'aide de la france à la
police tunisienne
cette fois ce sont ces dernières
vacances de noël en tunisie qui font la
une
selon le canard enchaîné michèle alliot
marie a utilisé le jet privé d'un proche
du clan ben ali pour rejoindre son lieu
de vacances alors qu'il y avait déjà les
premiers troubles dans le pays
et c'est vous il se couchait valoir qu
est monté au créneau dans l'hémicycle
julia le caureq ce matin à la sortie de
l'élysée premier démenti devant les
journalistes d'une ministre qui traverse
une zone de turbulences ce monsieur est
surtout une victime du clan ben ali il a
été spolié par monsieur rabeschi
et d'ailleurs les choses sont très
claires
puisque les tunisiens aujourd'hui l'on
réintroduit ce monsieur dans ses droits
en lui rendant sa part de capital et la
présidence de la société
voyez donc il n'y a absolument rien
michèle alliot marie et son compagnon
ont passé leurs vacances de noël en
tunisie
à l'époque la révolution tunisienne
était déjà engagée
plus grave les révélations du canard
enchaîné
la chef de la diplomatie française et
son compagnon aurait utilisé un jet
privé d'un homme d'affaires tunisien
présenté par le journal satirique comme
un membre du clan ben ali cet après midi
aux questions gouvernement la ministre
est attaqué et sommet tout simplement de
démissionner je vous le dis je suis
indigné et révolté par vos paroles et
votre comportement est très amicalement
et sobrement je vous dis madame partez
sous le regard attentionné de son
compagnon lui aussi ministre est lui
aussi présent lors de leur voyage
michèle alliot marie se défend une
nouvelle fois je vous rappelle que si je
prends mes vacances parfois en tunisie
c'est à mes frais voyages et hôtels
il m'a à aucun moment mis son avion à ma
disposition je l'aï accompagné pendant
vingt minutes de trajet en avion
une affaire de plus pour une ministre au
coeur des polémiques depuis deux mois
michèle alliot marie avait déjà été
critiquée pour une proposition de
coopération sécuritaire avec tunis le 11
janvier alors là mais nice est expliquée
à deux reprises depuis sur des plateaux
de télévision elle fait son mea culpa et
le porte parole du gouvernement dit mea
culpa est fait et maintenant on tourne
la page l'affairé close will est le
problème est que le bilan depuis un mois
et demi elle n'a cessé de ne pas faire
son mea culpa et de faire ce qu'on peut
appeler des erreurs même des fautes
politiques alors la première était en
effet après même
le fait qu'il eut un suicide monsieur
bouazizi là en tunisie donc quinzaine de
jours après elle va comme si de rien
n'était alors qu'il y avait déjà les 10
ans des rassemblements des émeutes et
donc des lits l'aspiration la révolution
et pour quelqu'un qui n'est pas elle a
dit mais je suis un citoyen comme un
autre je peux aller en vacances que je
veux c'est priver quand on est ministre
de la république même homme ou femme
politique en général on n'est pas un
citoyen comme un autre on notamment
quand on représente la france à
l'extérieur donc c'est une première
erreur la deuxième erreur évidemment l'a
vu aussi c'est lorsqu'elle a disons
proposé l'aide sécuritaire de la france
à ben ali
elle a nié qui est lisant du matériel
qui a été livrée entre il n'a pas été
livrée mais le premier ministre a avoué
que quand même il était prêt à être
livré plusieurs tonnes de grenades
lacrymogènes et enfin ce qui me paraît
le plus stupéfiant et inquiétant même
c'est qu'elle ne se rend pas compte de
l'impact de ces propos de son
comportement a l'air de dire que c'est
une petite affaire trouver leurs élus
tous et qu'il faut l'oublier non il ya
vraiment dans l'opinion publique et de
manière internationale donc dans l'image
de la france quelque chose qui s'est
dégradée qui s'est disqualifiée donc je
crois qu'elle elle devrait partir
mais apparemment le gouvernement et le
premier ministre à défendre et bien il y
a qu'en france qu'on voit des choses
comme ça en grande bretagne en allemagne
je crois que je serais parti depuis très
longtemps on peut qualifier ça
éventuellement de maladresse non parce
que le erreur politique c'est une erreur
politique c'est ça ce n'est pas une
erreur de langage parce que elle est
quand même très habituel la langue de
bois à la diplomatie ça fait quand même
dix ans pratiquement qu'elle est au
gouvernement
elle avait déjà été avant donc elle
maîtrise totalement je crois que par
exemple pour l'aide disant sécuritaire à
la tunisie
j'ai eu un accord même du président de
la république donc c'est elle qui a été
au charbon pour l'expliquer dans l'été
c'est un accord de gouvernement qui
globalement finalement a été aveugle à
six qui se passe est un petit peu comme
ils le sont actuellement pour l'egypte
et en plus alors elle même donc avec sa
famille est allée en tunisie au moment
de noël
il ya une des réalisations facile de
dire ça après coup ça que sur le moment
le dit elle même il n'y avait pas encore
de répression c'était il y avait déjà si
si elle ne dit donc
souvenez vous c'est une ampleur avec le
départ de ben ali et les morts qu'on
connaît derrière mais est-ce que à cette
époque là à ce moment là on peut pas
qualifier ça plus de maladresse que
réellement de fautes politiques
importantes
c'est pas quand on est ministre des
affaires étrangères numéro trois du
gouvernement on regarde surtout quand on
voit que quelque chose se passe
à condition que le vois moi ses facettes
moi j'appelle pas ça malleray j'appelle
cela erreurs ou fautes politiques
savaient pension et écouter morale ou
pas peu importe c'est le fait qu'on ne
voit pas ce qui se passe
une sorte d' aveuglement à des
événements qui était déjà sensible
depuis un certain temps moi je me
souviens on avait été en tunisie il ya
deux ans avec un parti qui avait été à
évidemment à l'époque totalement
interdite s'appelle simplement tunisie
verte et vous avez dit oui ça c'est une
dictature quand même c'est une dictature
un petit peu comme ils y parviennent
jeudi il y avait un débat à l'assemblée
sur la création de l'irena à abou dhabi
c'est l'agencé internationale des
énergies renouvelables et moi j'ai
critiqué gelé m alors que j'adore les
énergies renouvelables en tant
qu'écologiste mais abu dhabi c'est quand
même une dictature donc la france ne
peut pas se mentir ça il ya des pays qui
sont devenus infréquentables
bah oui alors vous allez me dire les
dictatures c'est la moitié des pays de
l'onu
donc il faut savoir mais entre eux
disons la fermeté et jaliens la lucidité
du président obama et le floch mort de
la diplomatie européenne notamment
française
il ya une grosse différence aller
mercredi toujours après les propositions
du rapport sauvé pour en finir avec les
conflits d'intérêts
le sénat se penche à son tour sur les
incompatibilités de certaines
professions avec les mandats
parlementaires gérard larcher a chargé
la commission des lois du sénat de
préparer un code de bonne conduite qui
n'épargne pas non plus les lobbys marie
brémaud le sénat souhaite afficher une
image irréprochable depuis un an et demi
un comité de déontologie réfléchit à
diverses améliorations en matière de
conflits d'intérêts et d'incompatibilité
parlementaire
des conclusions remises aujourd'hui au
président du sénat il appartient à la
commission des lois le moment venu de
rendre publiques ses conclusions et un
ordre des facteurs et ensuite à la
science publique de le faire en matière
de transparence totale il va donc
falloir attendre encore un peu si le cas
de quatre ou cinq sénateurs semble
soulever la question de
l'incompatibilité il n'est pas question
pour le moment de dévoiler au grand
public les noms ou les situations
toutefois certaines mesures vont
s'appliquer pour contrôler l'accès du
palais du luxembourg au lobby ainsi les
représentants des 100 de groupes
d'intérêts déclaré seront obligés de
porter un badge visible permettant de
les identifier
en matière de transparence le sénat veut
ouvrir la voie surtout à l'assemblée
nationale il m'a été demandé de recouper
avec l'assemblée nationale qui n'a pas
la même procédure que nous pour voir si
l'analyse que nous faisons la terre du
cdh à 3 ghz mais ne serait pas contourné
par notre assemblée
si les déplacements des sénateurs à
l'étranger financé par les lobbys
doivent être déclarés cette obligation
ne s'applique pas au palais bourbon
gérard larcher va donc tenter de
convaincre bernard accoyer de faire
jouer la transparence
ce qu'il faut également que les députés
déclarent leur voyage quand ils sont
financés par des professionnels quand
ils partent tous frais payés bien sûr je
crois que le rapport monsieur sauvette
un bon rapport en tout cas qui donne des
éléments de réflexion et qui serait bon
même qu'on puisse légiférer sur ce point
parce qu'il ya un flou en france alors
que dans d'autres pays c'est plus clair
par exemple au parlement européen
eh bien il ya des lobbys mais on sait
exactement qui sait ils ont pignon sur
rue et donc une certaine manière pas
simplement la transparence mais la
plaque possibilité d'avoir des
évidemment des conversations entre les
députés et puis les forces économiques
en l'occurrence est tout à fait clair au
contraire en france c'est nawa semblait
c'est pas clair il ya par exemple des
assistants parlementaires qui sont en
fait payés par les boîtes et puis il ya
même des gens qui ont d'une seule année
repas double salaire ça c'est interdit
enfin qui travaillent encore dans leur
propre boîte alors ça c'est pas bon du
tout il en est de même d'ailleurs ce
qu'on appelle le pantouflage
la vue avec monsieur françois pérol
paravent qui était secrétaire général
adjoint de l'elysée et qui a rejoint la
caisse d'étals les banques populaires
lire l'instant d'après au moment où il
n'est plus une idée plus allégés alors
qu'ils s'étaient occupés de la fait donc
il faut vraiment qui est non pas un mur
au sens une cloison ou les gens ne
puissent pas se parler mais qui une
différenciation totale entre le monde
politique un peu aussi avec le monde
économique
le monde aussi syndical associatif on
peut pas être en même temps dans
président de l'association et puis
député parce qu' il peut y avoir des
conflits d'intérêts on l'a vu avec la
ferveur on a le plus plein comme ça aux
états unis d'amérique
c'est beaucoup plus clair et au
parlement européen aussi on a vraiment
des lobbys qui sont là qui sont destinés
à discuter en tant que faure un petit un
petit badge là comme le proposent les
seniors ça peut être quelque chose parce
que je vois bien dans les couloirs de
l'assemblée
et on je connais pas mais dont je
soupçonne qu'ils le sont et lors
certains d'ailleurs ne se cache pas sur
les incompatibilités donc de certaines
professions avec les mandats
parlementaires gérard larcher dit
attention si un médecin ne peut plus
parler santé ou un éleveur agriculture
on risque un parlement en apesanteur et
ce qu'on n'aurait pas le temps
il s'agit de savoir si on peut continuer
à exercer moi je crois que le mandat de
parlementaire député ou sénateur
c'est un mandat à plein temps non
seulement je le dis pour d'autres
métiers extérieurs à la politique mais
je le dis même pour les métiers
intérieur je suis contre le cumul des
mandats
il ya des gens qui sont député maire
sénateur président du conseil général
mais comment font-ils
ou bien alors c'est les électeurs n'ont
pas voté pour lui ils ont voté
simplement parce qu'ils le connaissent
si c'est quelqu'un d'autre qui fait le
boulot à sa place verdun puis non je
vous en prie terminé jeudi qu' il y
avait en effet un parallèle entre le
cumul des mandats et une certaine
manière
l'ambiguïté entre le fait d'exercer un
métier dont à l'extérieur dans un
domaine économique bien sûr et le fait
d'être parlementaire parlementaire c'est
100 % et à fond là on a du temps à
discuter avec les syndicats les
associations les forces économiques ça
c'est normal
juste une petite question les deux
assemblées travail sur la question
chacune dans leur coin et au nom de la
séparation des pouvoirs ce sont les
parlementaires qui vont décider de leur
propre statut vous êtes sûr qu'on peut
arriver réellement à quelque chose dans
ces conditions le
le rapport me sauver donne des
indications qui ne s'adresse pas aux
parlementaires oui oui mais il n'est pas
anormal que les parlementaires choteau
saisissent alors l'écho dans des autos
logis ça peut exister mais ce qui est
mieux c'est les règlements intérieurs ou
là il est indiqué très clairement c'est
pas simplement pour la procédure
parlementaire
les parlementaires peuvent s'auto
discipliner c'est possible vous semblez
en août et madame je vous pose la
question ils sont ils sont là pour faire
la loi pour les autres et pour eux mêmes
ce que la loi s'applique à tout le monde
il ya pas de raison qu'il ne montre pas
l'exemple et qui soit même plus vertueux
que peut-être d'autres citoyens
on verra on passe à la journée de jeudi
dans la sphère du médiator le
laboratoire servier devant les sénateurs
c'est une première le laboratoire
servier dépêche un de ses responsables
pour s'expliquer le directeur
scientifique du laboratoire est
auditionné ce jeudi par les sénateurs de
la mission d'information sur le médiator
un responsable guerre bragarde bavard
pardon marie brémaud je suis de répondre
à vos questions je viens de répondre à
la représentation nationale
j'ai donné toutes mes réponses je vous
remercie d dégoûte mais je ne peux pas
répondre à cette question sans avoir
apporté un seul élément de réponse le
directeur scientifique de chez servier
repart muré dans son silence
son audition était attendue dans le
cadre de la mission parlementaire sur le
mediator
mais durant une heure et demie face aux
sénateurs il ne lâchera rien pierre shi
avis n'a rien vu rien fait bien sûr ce
n'est pas la bonne personne
côté vos posé beaucoup de questions
auxquelles malheureusement je n'ai pas
dit compétences
pour courir et pour moi il y a deux
jours anne castot en charge de
l'évaluation du risque
à l' agence française de sécurité
sanitaire des produits de santé accepte
elle de répondre aux interrogations mais
les explications sont brouillonnes vague
avoir incompréhensible quand on lui
demande pourquoi ne pas avoir retiré du
marché le médiator dès les premiers cas
suspects on peut se poser des questions
avoir des suspicions des préoccupations
des inquiétudes et interrogations sans
pour autant être capable de comment dire
établir et de conforter ses
interrogations qui n'ont été confortée
que bien après trouver les raisons d'un
si long sur 6 lui médiator malgré les
nombreuses alertes sur sa dangerosité
identifier les responsables et leur part
d'implication mettre en exergue les
failles d'un système de surveillance
la tâche s'annonce ardue pour la mission
sénatoriale
une première action tout à d'abord sur
les réticences du laboratoire servier à
s'expliquer oui c'est tout à fait
stupéfiant d'entendre le directeur
général il faut d'ailleurs remarquer que
ce n'est pas monsieur servier lui-même
qui est venu mais bon évidemment un
éminent membre de sa direction
j'espère bien oui et alors là aussi on
parlait tout à l'heure de conflit
d'intérêts apparemment là aussi un
énorme conflit d'intérêts mais ça n'est
pas que le laboratoire servier lui même
si c'est un scandale parce que le
médiator bon les fourchettes d'un entre
500 et 2000 morts dont c'est très grave
mais ça montre bien disons alors le
poids des lobbys pharmaceutiques en
france et en europe
ils sont tout à fait considérable parce
qu'il n'ya pas évidemment que les
laboratoires servier dont j'espère que
la hausse ira à quelque chose de plus
infranchissable entre les politiques
d'un côté et puis les laboratoires qui
ont le droit d'exister de l'autre mais
là le pouvoir de sarkozy est un petit
peu lisant mis en cause puisque bon ça
se passe à neuilly il a été décoré par
sarkozy enfin il ya vraiment une
connivence et donc il ya un conflit
d'intérêts un petit peu comme dans la
quart d'heure où il ya un conflit
d'intérêt entre être à la fois trésorier
de l'ump ministre du budget et puis
avoir par exemple sa femme qui était au
service de madame bettencourt avec ses
draps donc là on voit bien que là il
faut des murs quoi il faut vraiment
qu'ils aient une séparation très claire
pour que les gens puissent se discuter
ensemble
il faut pas qu'ils soient du même monde
une des pistes justement pour pour
l'afssaps agence du médicament et
qu'elles soient financés non plus parler
la branche armée par l'êta
est ce que c'est réellement une garantie
d'indépendance en tout cas ce sera plus
fort que par les laboratoires parce que
là on est sûr que les rapports vont être
un petit peu biaisé mais je crois que
l'état lui-même alors l'état c'est un
peu difficile à dire les intérêts à
défendre bien entendu mais c'est d'abord
l'intérêt général pas simplement un
intérêt industriel pour tel ou tel lot
champions nationaux
mais est ce que je vois c'est qu'il y a
trois missions sur le médiator il ya là
une du président de la république enfin
il a dépêché je crois monsieur debré pas
eu de volonté de quitter le travail
parlementaire de celui-ci parce que le
travail parlementaire d'une mission
parlementaire du sénat il y en a une je
crois que monsieur bapt à l'assemblée
nationale et leur voilà que monsieur
devrait le frère de l'autre bernard
debré et bien est missionné au 6 mai par
le président de la république
bon ça ça fait un peu je crois une
manière de noyer le poisson où on ne
sera pas parce que les conclusions
seront pas les mêmes
et ça finira peut-être pas en queue de
poisson j'espère mais ces îles il ya
quelque chose qui fait qu'augmenter les
soupçons plus on en fait et plus les
soupçons augmente de la part de nos
concitoyens sur les choses qui sont
graves parce que la santé publique
c'est le poste numéro un de nos
inquiétudes alan termine la semaine avec
la question du gaz de schiste révolution
énergétique pour les uns scandale
écologique pour les autres le collectif
sauvons les riches organisé cette
semaine un happening sur les
champs-elysées pour alerter la
population des dangers du gaz schisteux
jérémy hartmann
ce forage là avait tout d'une farce
potache mais les sols français pourrait
bien être explorées pour de vrai dès les
prochains jours alors ce matin sur les
champs-elysées
le collectif sauvons les riches
organisait un coup médiatique devant
l'hôtel marriott ou des industriels de
la pétrochimie devait se réunir
objectif faire connaître au grand public
une mesure prise en toute discrétion par
jean louis borloo avant de quitter le
ministère de l'écologie autoriser les
industriels à explorer le sous sol
français il recèlerait des quantités non
négligeables de pétrole et de gaz de
schiste
jean louis borloo notre cher ami des
écologistes a juste avant de partir a
signé 17 permis de l'exploration des gaz
de schiste un peu partout en france on
s'aperçoit petit peu du double discours
du gouvernement en la matière des
forages très polluant pour le paysage
d'abord mais aussi pour les nappes
phréatiques
un peu d'eau potable facturation du gaz
l'humour pour mieux vulgariser un sujet
éminemment sérieux cet après midi à
l'assemblée plusieurs députés de
l'opposition ont exprimé leur inquiétude
sur ces forages sur le banc du
gouvernement c'est nathalie kosciusko
morizet qui a remplacé jean louis borloo
la ministre de l'ecologie se veut
rassurant j'insiste sur le fait qu'il
s'agit bien d'exploration et non pas
d'exploitation et j'agis aucune
autorisation travaux n'est délivré sur
les permis d'exploration de gaz de
schiste
nathalie kosciusko morizet qui annonce
aujourd'hui la création d'une mission
pour évaluer les enjeux de
l'exploitation des gaz de schiste on l'a
pris jeudi donc le gouvernement suspend
les travaux de prospection de gaz du gaz
de schiste est ce que c'est une bonne
nouvelle
oui pour le gaz de schiste ça n'est pas
vrai pour lui le fisc est plutôt
francilienne cette fois ci mais on sait
quand on a vu les réalités américaines
et canadiennes et bien que les deux
techniques principales qui sont les plus
horizontaux les forages horizontaux et
puis la fracturation hydraulique sont
très impactantes pour l'environnement
alors bien sûr y un peu le matière il ya
du gaz où il ya un peu d'huile un peu de
pétrole mais c'est tellement dur pour
l'environnement aee salure tellement peu
de temps car ça montre comme ça on
produit un petit peu et observer sans le
déclin rapide
c'est pas comme ça qu'on va sauver
l'avenir énergétique de la planète ont
rencontré augmenter les gaz à effet de
serre il faut arrêter il n'y a aucun
moyen de 2 d'avoir des méthodes propres
de l'extraction de ces on reconnaissait
ces gaz et pétrole de schiste depuis
1820 donc simplement du fait que c'est
très très dispersées çà n'est pas les
poches comme il ya pour le pétrole ou le
gaz classique c'est très dispersé donc
il faut tout casser en dessous et les
nappes phréatiques la pollution de l'air
est terrible il faut cocher merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous sur ce
plateau pour commenter la semaine
delphine heures voire merci et on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine même lieu
même heure bonne semaine au revoir